what do an actor two olympic champions
and a government minister have in common
they're all card-carrying organ donors
they're campaigning for more germans to
join them
i personally don't think it would be
right to have these valuable organs
buried or cremated with me if i'm
declared brain dead
when i know that someone else could use
them to stay
for three years he's been waiting for a
new kidney
across germany 12 000 patients are
listed to receive donor organs
but the wait is long and about three of
them die every day
organ donations in germany are at a
record low after a scandal last year in
which a doctor manipulated data to get
one of his patients a new liver faster
since then new legislation is in place
to prevent tampering
we know that the new laws will not allow
an attempted manipulation like the one
we saw in the city of gottingen
in fact they make it impossible it's no
longer possible for one doctor to
determine the criteria for receiving an
organ or a patient's position on the
waiting list
now cases must be reviewed by three
doctors their transplantation
conferences and independent doctors make
the decisions
germany's health minister says he's
still angry about the scandal which
looks set to cost many more patients
their lives until the public's
confidence in organ donation is restored
you